Ross it's lovely to see you here at
learning forum on comic-con Windsor how
you been enjoying it today it's been
really lovely to be back at this
comic-con I think I did this comic-con
about two or three years ago when I met
you the first time Jan it's been a
lovely day and some of the costumes have
been absolutely phenomenal I saw some
elephant that looked like it was falling
to pieces
I just loved for some reason talking
about costumes I mean you get to wear
some amazing things don't you on Game of
Thrones and also on Doctor Who recently
as well tell me a little bit about your
favorite looks on each of those show Wow
well I mean I love my iconic look on
Game of Thrones series 2 in series 3 I
like the character as well in series 4
is obviously a little bit different a
little more chinny but the to Doctor Who
characters are so completely different
one of them's obviously very alien ish
the silence is very bold like head but I
really loved the teller this year he's
awesome just got those beautiful stock
like eyes and a beautiful little
mumbling mouth
I think the animatronics was something
new for me to work with as well so with
that out it I think millennium effects
did a beautiful job with the teller so I
really have enjoyed lust you know the
last three big creatures have been
playing and really amazing yeah has it
helped you when you put those
prosthetics on when you put that costume
on say for Game of Thrones we saw on
pour how does that kind of change how
you move how you walk how you think yeah
I mean it changes everything the thing
that I feel changes me the most oddly
enough is usually the teeth you put the
teeth in with the character and you kind
of really feel but that's that gives you
shape and you're in your face I finished
doing a horror movie this summer as well
called howl and and also just finished
something called the outer darkness and
both of those had amazing teeth and then
how I was playing a she-wolf and not so
she is like amazing fangs and this
crazy look about her and the teeth
really you know teeth or everything with
a werewolf I think as it is with a
vampire in the outer darkness as well I
have these amazing broken kind of crazy
teeth playing this insane croupier and
it's so yeah you have all that to look
forward to we're looking forward we hope
to seeing you in season five so what are
the chances are gonna see you is another
white Walker well I have a feeling this
season I'm not going to be able to do
Game of Thrones they asked me to come
back but I unfortunately had scheduling
conflicts that doesn't mean I'm out of
the picture there because there's a lot
of white Walker coming up in the future
I'm sure of that so fans won't be
disappointed and I'm sure I'll come back
to the mix at some point there's plenty
of white walkers to be used so how would
you like to return wow I would love to
return and murder somebody I mean I've
been pretty tame up until now I've not
really done anything or killed anybody
so I think it's my turn to kill somebody
I got killed in Series three and that
was fine it's time for me to murder
somebody the least likely person to kill
someone I know nice guy - in real life
but clearly not on set ask you about
season 4 episode 8 what we saw that
amazing scene the mountain versus a
Viper and what your reaction was to it
watching on screen I did I did freak I
have to say I was pretty I was really
shocked I didn't think it would be quite
as explicit as it was I did rewind and
watch it twice that's how sick I am I
was just impressed with how real it was
how disturbing it was how graphic it was
but I quite liked that sort of thing I'm
sounding really twisted now but I
thought it was fantastic as it was
emotional it was shocking it was
terrifying the reaction from his sister
it was just it was all very moving and
horrible and it was good what a way to
go yeah I know it's always great to go
out in fashion and his own style season
4 what have been your top apart from
over invested amounts of in your top WTF
moments where you've just gone
oh my god well the fight the Vipers
death was pretty much that I thought but
I also also Joffrey's death was pretty
amazing
it was really really wild I loved that
it was a really delivered it was good it
was a good death but I have to say also
charles dances death - it was incredible
at the very end that was shocking i
didn't expect that at all so i was a bit
like yeah what do you thinks gonna
happen now with Tyrion and Varys is
gonna for them as well I'm not her to be
Saint convinced that Charles sense is
dead because we didn't see him actually
you know in Kamath Thrones you're never
dead til you're dead so many people can
and possibly come back I mean he was
definitely severely wounded and dying I
haven't read the books so I don't know
he could still come back who knows David
and Dan have talked about flashbacks are
gonna use flashbacks of first time
recently who would you like to see
return in a flashback
milto's of course I would love to see
milto's return I actually when he died
and I'm talking about you milto's I want
to see you return I want you to return
return come come back he's back now
don't go please
but yeah when I saw that scene in there
very free I thought no way no he didn't
why and I also thought it you know it
happened kind of off-screen you just
heard a yell and I caught though did he
really die well I think he should come
back in flashback sequence sort of like
in Star Wars you know like that kind of
pick up and serve again come on
yes so that's why I would love to see I
love it let's make it happen Ross it's
been a delight talking to you as always
thank you so thanks a lot John I'll see
soon
you